it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you pull up your sleeves
and get your creativity flowing with
Mario maker you basically get two games
in one it's a design tool but it's also
a traditional 2d platformer you get to
pick your graphical skins from the
original mario super mario bros 3 or
super mario world or even the New Super
Mario Bros u and it changes the world
and the musical themes based on what you
pick you can make so many amazing
incredibly difficult levels and there's
only one thing you have to do to share
it publicly you have to beat it and that
means there you're gonna be going over
the level again and again and again
trying to finish the most diabolical
Mario levels that have ever been created
gamespot's own Justin hey Walt gave the
game a glowing nine out of 10 so if
you're a fan this is a no-brainer start
experimenting with goombahs on the 11th
also coming out another beloved game
although much much younger it's tearaway
it's stepping out of the vita box and
onto the playstation 4 with tearaway
unfolded the game is an expanded remake
of the 2014 vita game and similarly to
the first the player controls the
messenger ottawa who is tasked with
delivering a message to a portal that is
opened in the sky along with the you
enemy is known as scraps are invading
the world via the opening throughout the
adventure ottawa will traverse many new
and reworked levels to reach the portal
and save their paper world bust out your
Dualshock 4 on the 8th
we also get a point-and-click claymation
adventure with armikrog and if you think
some of it looks similar to earthworm
jim you're not crazy pencil test Studios
is working with Doug ten napal who
created that character he also worked
alongside the studio for the neverhood
armikrog will center around Tommy not
who's a space explorer and crash lands
on a weird planet he ends up locked in a
strange fortress called armikrog along
with BP is blind talking dog you don't
see games like this come along very
often so I'd recommend picking it up and
enjoying it on the 8th just a few games
for you to consider this week 3d s
rhythm game hatsune miku project more
idx gives you full length songs on the
11 cute little fuzzball Leo's fortune
moves from iOS into full HD on ps4 and
xbox one on 8 and trippy circular
platformer circa infinity comes out on
September ninth
the beloved Kickstarter game Broken
Sword five the Serpent's curse is coming
back to ps4 and xbox one courtesy of
revolution software and Kickstarter
backers George and Nico are on the trail
of a stolen painting and some pretty
gruesome murders you guide both of them
via point-and-click to solve the crimes
and stay alive while death scenes were
removed from the shadow of the templars
director's cut which was in 2009 in the
Serpent's curse you can kill your
players if you make the wrong decision
or you don't complete an action quickly
enough you head to Paris on
finally as you might know i just love
couch co-op and there's not too many
coming out these days lovers in a
dangerous space-time is a frenetic 122
player couch co-op action space shooter
and you have to get to the right station
to man turrets lasers shields and
thrusters we got to do it all with your
buddy if you don't have a couch buddy
space pet will be given to you and
depending on how good your friend is the
pet might be better you'll work together
to take down large bosses and explore a
vast depth of space and I mentioned
space bunnies because you can rescue
space bunnies become a member of the 400
mile high club on the 9th for further
details visit gamespot com release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change see you next week
music